wenn man bei ganz vielen sachen die wir
putin da gesagt hat wenn man da keine
streicht und russland einsetzen hat er
recht weil wenn er davon spricht dass um
die gleichen herrschen dass kein
rechtsstaat herrscht dass keine freiheit
herrscht dann kann er eigentlich nur
seinen landmann und übt sich wirklich
wieder zum zum krieg und man muss es so
drastisch sagen wladimir putin hat
gestern die sicherheits ordnung europas
einfach auf den müll geworfen wer hat
gestern mit dieser rede mit der
ankündigung truppen rein zu schicken
wirklich die schlussakte die kst die
kasse die schlussakte auf der der
frieden in europa das friedliche
zusammenleben auch zwischen dem den
blöcken früher bestanden hat worauf das
alles fuß das hat er gestern mit füßen
getreten in die tonne getreten und er
hat vor allem die minsker vereinbarung
allesamt zerrissen und ebenfalls auf den
müll geworfen also alle vereinbarung
alle verträge die unser zusammenleben
die regel dass man andere staaten nicht
nicht angreift dass man friedliche
koexistenz hat das hat er alles gestern
vernichtet aus russischer sicht erst
gestern quasi aus dieser aus dieser
wertegemeinschaft ausgetreten er macht
das gleiche was er mit der krim gemacht
hat er hat gesehen haben wir damit durch
richtig und macht jetzt das gleiche
nochmal in der hoffnung dass es wieder
so geht und für die ukraine ist das im
prinzip jetzt hält man noch die zweite
wange hin und es gab gestern haben eine
ganz interessante erklärung des
bundeskanzlers nach einem telefonat mit
dem us präsident biden und frankreichs
präsidenten mag der ist jetzt zweiter
absatz ist der ist entscheidende wo man
die der ukraine dafür dankt dass sie
unter ihrem präsidenten see lynskey
solche zurückhaltung an den tag gelegt
hat und man werde sich weiterhin dafür
einsetzen dass die territoriale
integrität der ukraine bestehen bleibt
und wir sollen das passiert richtig weil
sie ist gebrochen die krim ist weg die
ost ukraine ist jetzt weg da steht auch
ich sage mal ganz pauschalen der russe
drin das ist alles weg und die
territoriale integrität der ukraine ist
nicht mehr da wladimir putin hat
angeordnet truppen sogenannte
friedensgruppen in die ost ukraine zu
schicken da können wir einfach osten
streichen er schickt sie in die ukraine
er schickt sie in ein fremdes land er
schickt sie dorthin wo er bisher immer
geleugnet hat dass er damit irgendetwas
zu tun hat hat er immer so getan als
eines freischalt aufständische die der
ukrainische aufständischen die dort die
dort herrschen aber es war immer ein
militärregime unterstützt von den russen
inszeniert von den russen finanziert von
moskau wie wird es jetzt weitergehen
annalena baerbock hat gestern putin
aufgerufen machen sie diesen schritt
rückgängig was natürlich niemals
passieren wird sonst hätte er ihn gar
nicht erst mitgemacht lassen sie die
pflanzen rückwärts wachsen das
funktioniert nicht und das wird auch
nicht passieren wladimir putin hat jetzt
eins gemacht hat klar gemacht dass wir
noch über irgendetwas verhandelt dann
nicht mehr darüber ob er irgendwo
einmarschiert sondern ob man noch
weitergeht er steht jetzt wieder drei
meter oder zehn meter in der ukraine
drin er ist da er hat beide füße drin
aber gelte es sein dass ihm das reicht
weil er eigentlich auch nach innen hin
nachdem er diese eskalation so aufgebaut
hat nach innen auch irgendwas liefern
muss ich habe auch irgendetwas damit
erreicht kann er sagen seht ihr leute
ich habe etwas erreicht und das reicht
mir etwa jetzt gibt es über sanktionen
die werden wir schon irgendwie
wegstecken aber wir haben wieder das
erreicht was wir erreichen wollten
wladimir putin wird jetzt warten welche
reaktionen aus dem westen kommen das hat
er gestern abend schon relativ gut
funktioniert das kam gestern aus dem
westen erst mal nichts außer der
ankündigung dass es sanktionen gegen die
separatisten gebiete geben wird hallo
dritten da ist niemand aus dem westen
tätig was wollen wir machen weil wir den
die luft weg nehmen mehr können wir das
nicht machen es ist absolut lächerlich
sanktionen gegen die separatisten
gebieten sie können gut funktioniert hat
die kreditkarte nicht das ist dann aber
auch schon irgendwie also man kann sich
dann kein sex wagen mieten wenden und
aus dem westen kommen die zustände die
wir jetzt auf der krim aber wenn man auf
die auf die krim reist funktionieren
würde die karten nicht funktionieren
westliche handy
die ganzen restlichen handyverträge
nicht das ist alles also das ist absolut
lächerlich wladimir putin hat mehrere
probleme einst hat er gestern vorläufig
gelöst eine legitimation nach innen also
ich lade mir putin das war gestern den
ganzen tag über eine fürchterliche ins
inszenierung hatte seine ganzen minister
sein kabinett antreten lassen und hat
argumentieren dass ein für und gegen die
anerkennung dieser gebiete am ende
musste auch der sicherheitsrat der ja
die versammelt hatte jeder musste wie in
der schule wurde gut angenommen und
musste sagen ob er dafür ist ja dagegen
so hat er sich natürlich auch unter den
chef des auslandsgeheimdienstes richtig
abgekanzelt der sieg war quasi finden
wollte und als er sich raus halten
wollte abgekanzelt entschuldigung da saß
gestern ein ich sage mal gesagt dass man
ein fest dass ein feister zwar auf
seinem tränchen in kreml hat vor tanzen
lassen und das zweite problem ist dass
laut putin hat uns frage dann noch
schnell zu beantworten
ist dass er den landweg zur krim braucht
die grünbrücke reicht ihm nicht unter
muss diesen landweg haben aus seiner
sicht und ich bin fest davon überzeugt
dass er sich den wie auch immer holen
wird